qui sera le prochain chef du parti
québécois le long du nouveau chef sera
connu le 9 octobre la cour s'est passé
pas mal sous le radar alors que la
province était plongé en pleine pandémie
mais dès le 5 octobre les quelques
trente quatre mille membres du pq
pourront choisir celui qui dirigera le
parti fondé il ya 52 ans qui était
dirigé ses débuts bien sûr le premier
chef c'est rené lévesque
je reçois ce soir les quatre candidats à
la chefferie frédéric bastien sylvain
gaudreault pour sa pierre plamondon
guy nantel bonsoir à vous quatre vous a
convié pour répondre à des questions le
débat vous l'avez fait pas mal pendant
la campagne mais dans le fond je vais
vous de savoir est ce que le pq a sa
raison d'être parce à perdre à mende ont
évidemment parce que le québec un destin
qui attend d'être complétée c'est celui
de notre indépendance de la normalité
pour tous les québécois puis on a
découvert pendant la crise avec l'aco
viennent que il ya bel et bien un
gouvernement de trop que ce soit nos
frontières que ce soit le contrôle sur
l'armée le contrôle sur les aréoports la
collaboration par rapport à la pcu on
voit que le gouvernement du québec au
quotidien o maille à partir avec ce
gouvernement là c'est notre argent mais
ce ne sont pas nos décisions et
l'indépendance du québec c'est donc un
sujet actuel un projet d'avenir est donc
évidemment que le parti québécois à sa
place sylvain gaudreault bien sûr le
parti québécois est plus pertinent que
jamais l'accolade entre autres démontré
que l'état nation est plus pertinent que
jamais mais également il faut avoir
l'indépendance si on veut atteindre nos
objectifs si on veut faire notre part
également dans la lutte contre la crise
climatique pour moi la question du
climat la question démographique la
question du numérique entre autres c'est
des grands enjeux de l'heure ça passe
par l'indépendance du québec guy nantel
oui ben en fait seuls partis
nationalistes et souverainistes au
québec c'est le parti québécois donc le
jour où il y aura cette option là qui
sera morte je pense que 60 question de
temps avant que on se refait de la
langue de
culture québécoise ribas est la question
nationale
une question qui transcende la question
de plusieurs d'autres questions de paix
qu incarne le combat pour la nation
québécoise et combat pour statut du
québec dans le canada le maintien de
notre culture donc c'est évident que ce
ces questions là demeurent pertinentes
et que le pic a son rôle à jouer
là-dedans bien sûr alors à tous les 4
pourquoi c'est si difficile le parti
québécois de ceux de maintenir sa place
lui qui est en déclin depuis tant
d'années madame marois qui publie sa
biographie la pauline marois delà du
pouvoir raconte l'une des raisons de la
défaite c'est quand les québécois se
sont aperçus qu avec pierre karl
péladeau l'option souverainiste devait
être crédible que ça peut peut-être pas
peur bien des québécois mais que ça
arrive jouit le parti libéral guy nantel
alors si vous prenez l'indépendance
c'est difficile à convaincre les
québécois on va écouter c'est sûr que
défi pour un parti souverainiste est
toujours plus grande pour un parti c'est
si on se prend pas au parti libéral
comme vous le faites le programme du
parti libéral c'est à dire tout va bien
tout est parfait évidemment c'est plus
simple d'écrire un programme que juste
une comme une saveur économique mais
évidemment quand on veut changer le
système
forcément il ya plus grand défi ça peut
faire part au monde à priori mais je
pense qu'un moyen et à long terme si
nous on assume qui on se met à en parler
après ça la population va embarquer puis
c'est peut-être ça qu'on n'a pas
toujours fait dans le parti dans les
dernières années
sylvain boudreau ben moi je pense qu'il
faut convaincre les gens avec une
démonstration sur des enjeux qui sont
contemporains qui sont claires par
exemple sur l'aspect culturel avec notre
capacité de taxer par exemple les google
amazon facebook apple de ce monde sur
l'enjeu climatique on peut pas rester
dans un pays pétrolier englué dans ses
sables bitumineux alors si on veut jouer
un rôle sur le plan climatique si on
veut être le premier pays vert au monde
ça nous prend indépendante est également
vous savez moi je suis extrêmement
convaincu aussi qu'il faut faire notre
travail de notre bord on a une
responsabilité
ça veut dire d'être capable de répondre
de façon concrète à des questions que se
posent les citoyens sur l'indépendance
et ça j'ai préparé un plan pour y
arriver avec des réponses pour
l'élection 2022
les mafias oui moi je pense que la
parlotte pyatt la cote on va se parler
on va parler de souveraineté c'est pas
ça qui va faire monter les appuis je
pense que l'histoire nous enseigne que
l'appui à la souveraineté intimement
liée à la question constitutionnelle
alors moi ce que je dis c'est premier
mandat constitution deuxième mandat
référendum bing bang et moi je pense que
c'est en forçant ces discussions là
qu'on fasse des gains qu'on n'en fasse
pas la souveraineté elle va gagner plus
depuis les différences du québec c'est
un projet d'avenir
donc on peut discuter longuement de la
trajectoire du parti québécois se
concentrer uniquement sur la partie mais
en fait ce qui compte la vraie question
c'est ce que l'indépendance comme projet
a un avenir
et le jour où on veut laisser autre
chose à nos enfants que le mépris le
déclin que nous réserve le canada il y a
un avenir pour l'indépendance puis là ce
moment là comme militant comme politique
on se pose plus la question c'est quoi
les probabilités c'est quoi les sondages
on est là parce qu'on y croit on est là
parce que notre idée les légitimes et
qu'on veut que le pays ait lieu pour
qu'on soit un peuple normal une
démocratie normale et je pense que c'est
très légitime et que c'est ce qu'on va
faire valoir au cours des prochaines
années avec vigueur avec énergie
dynamisme est ce que la caq avec son
nationalisme et la lutte qu'elle mène
face à ottawa ne vous a pas volé un peu
trop tirer le tapis sous les pieds au pq
et sylvain gaudreault moi je pense que
la caq fait au contraire la
démonstration d'un nationalisme de
façade dont le vus de façon éclatante
entre autres sur la question des
transferts en santé
sur la question du discours à la nation
du discours du trône de monsieur trudeau
avec un ton très arrogant sur la
question des décès h et celle des par
exemple on le voit aussi sur la question
de l'environnement il faut que le québec
aille jusqu'en cour suprême sur la
question de la taxe carbone ou du port
de québec pour faire en sorte que ce
sont les lois environnementales du
québec qui s'appliquent sur des projets
d'envergure qui viennent toucher le
québec
alors on est dans une situation monsieur
legault d'un bourassa 2.0 un
nationalisme de façade qu'il faut
démasquer et c'est ainsi qu'on va faire
là la démonstration de la pertinence
d'indépendance aussi est ce pas
nécessairement facile pour vous envoyer
le taux de d'approbation du gouvernement
de pandémie quand même pas que saint
père de la mandole de l'acca qui avaient
du succès mais là en effet il y aurait
un vrai questionnement peut-être du côté
du parti québécois mais en fait
l'opportunité est là c'est que la caq ce
n'est pas du dre nationalisme récemment
là on vient d'apprendre des projets
d'anglicisation qui accélère
l'anglicisation à travers de pl 66
chacune des demandes au gouvernement
fédéral s'est vu recevoir un non
retentissant dont claquettes n'obtient
pas de gain et démontre à chacune de ces
demandes que ça fonctionne pas donc il
va y avoir une vraie discussion
une vraie croisée des chemins entre sexe
et accepter que ça ne fonctionne pas et
se coucher par terre ou reprendre un peu
l'esprit d'aventuré avoir un peu de
fierté nous mêmes puis dire là il faut
se donner un avenir un meilleur avenir à
nos enfants que ça c'est pas que cet
après des glaciers oui bien regarder la
cac qui veut renforcer la loi 101 qui
demande aux fédéraux d'étendre la loi
101 aux entreprises à charte fédérale et
là monsieur legault reçu une claque en
pleine face de la part de monsieur
trudeau à ottawa si monsieur legault
test sérieux efforts ce sera une
discussion constituaient l'une
négociations constitutionnelles comme il
en a le pouvoir
mais c'est très bien que ça va faire le
jeu du parti québécois alors ils
s'écrasent et il se couche par terre le
tueur rejoint sylvain gaudreault est un
nationalisme de façade sauf pour la loi
21 et on ironise guy nantel avant
d'aller 9 noeuds en fait monsieur
legault avait fait dix-huit
revendications qui avait proposé donc
qui parlait de ça durant la dernière
campagne électorale en disant qu'ils
allaient aller chercher 18 points et
dans ses 18 points en ce moment il est 0
en 18 à leur sens dit non à partir du
moment où il y en a aussi qui aurait
plus jamais de référendum mais je pense
que
le canada a absolument rien à gagner ni
à perdre à négocier avec ces gens là il
ya une course à la chefferie du parti
québécois vous avez vous voyez dans vous
les quatre candidats les membres les 30
quelques maisons peuvent voter dès le 5
octobre
résultat le 9 octobre c'est un peu comme
une audition là frédéric bastien
pourquoi vous devriez chef du parti
québécois qu'est ce qui ferait de vous
un bon chef meilleurs chefs que tous les
autres et ben je suis le seul qui a un
vrai plan participer je veux forcer
négociations constitutionnelles on a le
pouvoir de faire ça ça c'est un geste
concret qu'on peut faire qu'on peut
poser son image au retur à la prochaine
élection
et ça je suis convaincu que ça va faire
mousser les appuis à la souveraineté
quelle que soit l'issue de cette
négociation
mes adversaires ça revient toujours à
parler vous parler on va expliquer on va
placoter de souveraineté puis l'appui à
la magie va monter mais moi je ne crois
pas ça et j'ai prouvé que je pouvais
mettre les fédéraux sur la défensive
sylvain boudreau ben moi je pense que la
vraie question qui se pose c'est qui le
plus fiable pour transformer le parti
vert l'enjeu du 21ème siècle qui est
celui des changements climatiques mais
également le transformer pour faire en
sorte que le national la permanence soit
au service des circonscriptions et des
militants qui peut gouverner moi j'ai
déjà exercé la fonction de ministre je
suis déjà l'assemblée nationale et puis
et qui peut faire gagner ce parti pour
les prochaines élections faire gagner la
souveraineté moi j'ai cinq élections à
mon actif où j'ai tout gagné mais
élections alors moi je pense que c'est
moi qui correspond le plus à ces
critères et c'est ce que j'ai proposé
aux militants kim connexes et que je
connais point saint pierre vous seriez
le meilleur mais la question de fond
c'est qu'ils incarnent l'avenir on veut
le chef des dix prochaines années du
parti québécois pas le chef des dix
dernières années et donc si on faut
regarder dans cette course le qui est
capable de parler autant aux jeunes
qu'aux plus vieux qui est capable de
percer le mur de l'indifférence prendre
la place médiatique pour les bonnes
raisons
donc je pense que le vrai choix pour les
membres c'est le choix de la continuité
ou le changement et je pense que ce
changement lui il doit être crédible
et énergique un changement qui est
positif et c'est ce que ma campagne
incarner tout le long de ces neuf mois
de campagne
guy nantel le campagne puis vraiment je
pense qu'on a quatre personnes qui
pourraient gagner la course qui seraient
des bons chefs mais je suis quand même
parce que je vous dirais il ya eu deux
sondages qui sont assez contradictoires
et qui sont selon moi les chiffres sont
bons dans les deux cas il y en a un sur
la population dont qui est auprès de la
population en général où je suis de loin
en avance en fait on additionne les
trois adversaires et on arrive à ce que
vous aviez de l'envié comme on dit mais
non non pas du tout car c'est vraiment
ce genre mauriac qui a fait ça c'est pas
elle qui commande des sondages parmi
nous donc voilà on a commandé 1 puis je
fais une blague parce que je suis
convaincu que ces chiffres sont corrects
donc à l'intérieur des militants
palestiniens sont de loin en avant lors
la question qu'il faut se demander c'est
est ce qu'on veut voter pour quelqu'un
qu'on aime bien
ou est-ce qu'on veut voter pour
quelqu'un un coup qu'on a un chef qui va
gagner l'élection parce qu'avec moi on
est premiers déjà première opposition
officielle tandis qu'avec nos
adversaires on est là la troisième
opposition officielle c'est une
différence énorme et qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire parce que martine desjardins
et collègues ainsi que le l'enjeu de la
surêté pas un danger pour les jeunes
vrai que d'évoquer ses vins gaudreault
les enjeux climatiques
mais don quelle souveraineté à saint
paul sport pour les jeunes on est
ailleurs
c'était bon et 50 ans nous il ya 20 ans
où il alors qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
pont saint pierre plamondon qu'on peut
vraiment parler aux jeunes des classes
ouvertes et les intéressés complet
lancer ce parti là mais dans ma campagne
les bénévoles sont dans la vingtaine
dans la trentaine on a aussi des
militants de la première heure mais
c'est absolument faux le puis moi je les
fais la tournée des cégeps et des
universités notamment dans rose y
repenser le pq you de l'intérêt pour un
projet de société mais il faut que le
parti québécois s'assume faut dire on va
avoir du fun au cours des prochaines
années parce qu'on va militer pour notre
raison d'être sans s'excuser en disant
voici un projet de société où on va
pouvoir faire les choses différemment
pas juste sur le plan environnemental
mais sur le plan linguistique sur le
plan du rayonnement international
un projet à bâtir ensemble
l'espace boursiers dans toutes les
générations on entend souvent cette
rengaine mais elle n'est pas fondée et
ma campagne le démontre très clairement
en fait d'une version dans le connu des
guerres constitutionnel qu'est ce qu'il
faut dire que les jeunes loups que les
québécois ben oui mais madame du show le
discours que vous tenez c'est le même
discours du milieu de la question vous
poser au milieu d'un chaos milieu des
années 80 on disait voilà les jeunes
s'intéressent plus à ça et puis est
arrivé l'échec du lac meech et là les
jeunes étaient dans la rue donc la
question nationale et il faut la poser
de façon concrète et la seule façon de
poser de façon concrète c'est de force
et de négociations constitutionnelles
c'est pas en parlant à de souveraineté a
malheureusement je le regrette mais
c'est en parlant de souveraineté que les
appuis vont monter sylvain boudreau mais
imaginez que vous êtes né en 1990
madame du soja c'est bizarre mais je
suis ça veut dire ça veut dire que dès
que vous avez eu conscience de la vie
politique là c était la commission
charbonneau la commission gomery ça et
lé gouvernement de jean charest de
philippe couillard l'austérité et il ya
eu deux grands moments là d'un
mobilisation collective la grève de 2012
est l'année passée pareille date cinq
cent mille personnes dans les rues sur
les changements climatiques
alors notre enjeu à nous c'est à dire
banque t5 this lollipop ont peu de
points il ne faut pas être cynique c'est
existe la mobilisation collective il
faut maintenant passer à l'action et le
plus grand changement d'un monde qui est
proposé c'est le pq qu'il l'a essaie de
faire du québec un pays
alors les jeunes vont venir avec nous
mais il faut en être convaincu que les
invités à le faire
guy nantel point on vit dans une ère un
petit peu plus individualiste qu
autrefois que c'est vrai qu'en général
je pense qu'il ya moins de jeunes qui
sont mobilisés politiquement tous partis
confondus
mais il faut pas oublier que le parti
québécois l'ailé jeunesse du parti
québécois qu'on plus de manque d al
jeunesse des trois autres partis
additionner ensemble alors je comprends
pas pourquoi on propage toujours cette
idée là que les jeunes ne s'intéressent
plus à la souveraineté alors que c'est
nous qui tirons plus de gens alors il
reste à peine 30 secondes un mot chacun
secondes chacun un mot qui vous définit
fin d'exercice est un mot qui me définit
bel espoir et saint pierre de la bande à
un changement constructif
sylvain boudreau indépendance creemore
et fiabilise sur ces trois mots et pas
un autre appareil guy nantel victoire
alors écoutez merci à vous quatre
quiconque s'engage en politique par les
temps qui courent c'est quand même très
courageuse il faut avoir les reins
solides ne faut pas avoir peur de
l'affronter souvent des tempêtes
merci tous les cadres de votre
engagement et on va suivre les derniers
jours et le résultat avec beaucoup
d'intérêt merci